oui
[Musique]
ce président est monsieur le président
je tiens à vous remercier pour avoir
accordé à la chaîne rte votre premières
interviews pour la presse internationale
en tant que président à les imiter les
camaro à la première question concernera
bien sûr vos impressions personnelles
après la rencontre avec vladimir poutine
ainsi que les relations russo iranienne
40 quel est le niveau de rapprochement
entre moscou et téhéran aujourd'hui moi
ce quoi iti graff nationale
au nom d'allah le miséricordieux
je tiens à remercier votre média
je suis très heureux d'être à moscou et
d'avoir eu hier et aujourd'hui aussi des
réunions avec des représentants de haut
rang du gouvernement russe va vous aider
rolls end
lors de la rencontre avec vladimir
poutine
nous avons discuté des relations
bilatérales
ainsi que des questions régionales et
internationales sur les
allées de manière générale
avec cette discussion avec le président
russe les chasser bord je me suis aperçu
que nos positions étaient identiques
elles étaient les mêmes sur de nombreux
sujets
et nous avons des intérêts communs avec
la russie
en plus d'être voisin
la russie et nous sommes membres
d'organisations régionales et
internationales
nous pouvons coopérer par le biais de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai ocs
il y a beaucoup d'opportunités en russie
en iran
et ses opportunités peuvent ouvrir la
voie à une interaction encore plus
avancés sur les questions économiques
dans les domaines de la science de la
technologie de l'aérospatiale ainsi que
de la défense et de la sécurité des deux
pays
il ya donc beaucoup de prédisposition au
développement de notre coopération et
compte tenu de la volonté des hauts
responsables des deux pays
tous ces domaines seront développés
le terrain pour le développement de nos
relations dans d'autres domaines est
également en train d'être préparée
mais nos relations avec la fédération de
russie ne seront pas des relations de
court terme
il s'agira d'une relation l'idée d'une
coopération sur des bases solides
mutuellement bénéfique dans les intérêts
de nos deux pays et de nos deux peuples
et nous travaillons à faire en sorte que
nos relations deviennent stratégiques
fortes afin qu'elles puissent assurer
nos interactions à l'avenir
rwandais les odes à lennon ainsi nissan
un document stratégique est à cet égard
en cours d'élaboration inde et il
portera sur 20 ans et n'a dès lors guère
mais ce document stratégique qu'on
élabore en ce moment en une et qui
portera sur 20 ans est un document
exhaustif qui couvre l'intégralité des
domaines de coopération
ce document peut déterminer de manière
aboutissent les perspectives pour tous
les acteurs économiques du marché et le
mirent dans le domaine de la technologie
de la défense et ainsi de suite ma soeur
est morte à l'aise comme nan shan
parlez nous du document stratégique
combien de l'accord entre la russie et
l'iran
précisera damas couacs au bout d'une à
quel point cette coopération sera t-elle
étroite et que faut-il attendre de
l'alliance entre la russie et l'iran ça
use de cette alliance stratégique ici
comment
voyez-vous
nos relations avec la fédération de
russie et avec tous les autres pays
seront fondées sur des intérêts communs
en sur une interaction fructueuse
mais là c'est à dire une interaction
entre pays qui aboutira à un résultat
est ce que nous ressentons c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nos relations sont
conformes aux principes que nous avons
en iran ou souligne mandat autrement dit
le principe fondamental est que nous ne
voulons pas dominer les autres pays
et ne sommes pas prêts à être dominée
par d'autres pays c'est le principe
il n'est pas question de prix mais les
autres à cela et il n'est pas question
d'être sous le joug d'autres b
ainsi suite à la victoire de la
révolution islamique
nous avons élaboré ce principe selon
lequel notre pays devait être un état
indépendant
et aujourd'hui nos liens avec la russie
sont fondés sur le fait que la russie
souhaite être un état indépendant
et c'est ce qui fait l'objet des
attaques d'ailleurs ou doux mais les
occidentaux des américains
c'est bel et bien aux pays qui veulent
être indépendants que les ennemis s'en
prennent
donc suite à la révolution l'iran
islamique a décidé de devenir
indépendant de ne se laisser dominer par
personne dans le monde
en même temps l'iran lui même ne veut
pas non plus dominer les autres pays
voilà notre principe
or quand vous voulez vivre de manière
indépendante vous êtes bien sûr attaqué
par les pays qui veulent dominer les
américains ne veulent pas d'états
indépendants dans le monde il veut le
faire de ces pays leurs esclaves
mais pendant 40 ans par la grâce que
nous a donné la révolution islamique
bien sûr nous avons résisté à la
domination américaine
et nos relations avec la fédération de
russie seront fondées sur le principe du
respect des intérêts communs sur notre
interaction autour de diverses questions
liées à l'agenda régional internationale
sur le fait que les deux états font
partie d'organisations régionales et
internationales
ainsi que sur nos interactions au niveau
de l'agenda bilatéral
aujourd'hui plusieurs experts hommes
politiques et médias occidentaux font
preuve d'hystérie à cause du partenariat
stratégique entre la russie et l'iran
pourquoi cette hystérie et quel est
l'objectif final de ces spéculations
l'iran est une puissance importante et
un état indépendant
aux siens la russie est aussi un état
puissant et influent
et quand deux pays puissants se mettent
ensemble et cherche à coopérer chine et
cela suscite bien sûr une réaction
d'horreur chez ceux qui ont l'intention
de dominer
en nous exprimant sur notre politique
étrangère nous avons dit que nous
allions coopérer avec tous les pays du
monde que nous allions interagir
il s'agit d'une interaction avec tous
les pays du monde
et si certains pays veulent se
comportait de manière hostile envers
nous alors ils devront évidemment faire
face à notre résistance
la résistance du peuple iranien
et c'est ce que nous avons montré au
cours des 40 dernières années
c'est que nous sommes un peuple qui
n'accepte pas la force et qui n'est pas
sous le joug de la domination de cas que
ce soit
mon remettre le fait que le peuple
iranien est capable de résister à
aujourd'hui était prouvé à tous les pays
du monde deux chevaliers nakhonay si
personne ne veut d'hostilité bien sûr
nous coopérerons et interagiront donc
dès le début nous avons dit au sein du
gouvernement que notre priorité était
d'interagir avec les états voisins
c'est pour cette raison que nous sommes
favorables à une coopération dans tous
les domaines avec les états voisins et
nous nous sommes engagés dans une
démarche diplomatique de bon voisinage
parce que cela profitera à la fois aux
habitants de la région et à l'économie
mondiale dans son ensemble
parlez nous s'il vous plaît de l'état
d'avancement des négociations sur un
sujet très important
la question nucléaire
espérez vous vous mettre d'accord à
vienne et pourriez-vous peut-être évoqué
en détail ce qui se déroule bien et ce
qui ne va pas
acheter un cachot
concernant les négociations
nous avons pris très au sérieux notre
participation à la fraude et si les
partis qui nous sont opposés sont prêtes
à lever les sanctions
alors il y aura un terrain pour parvenir
à un accord la chine
mais ce que nous avons vu jusqu'à
présent c'est une violation des
obligations de la part des américains et
l'absence de nouvelles mesures
appropriées de la part des européens
autrement dit les européens n'ont pas
non plus rempli leurs engagements
américains ont aussi officiellement
violé l'accord
d'autre part jusqu'à présent l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique a
annoncé à 15 reprises que l'iran s'était
acquitté de ses obligations
et qu'il était attaché à ses obligations
on ne rend que c'est pourquoi je tiens à
dire que nous avons rempli nos
engagements et eux ne l'ont pas fait ils
ont contrevenu
ils doivent y revenir ceux qui l'ont
violée ils doivent rétablir ces choses
en exécutant leurs obligations
nous nous n'avons rien violée par
conséquent ce qu'ils ont annoncé eux
mêmes et que nous avons respecté dès le
début nos engagements nous avons rempli
nos obligations en vertu de cet accord
ils ont manqué aux leurs par conséquent
si les parties sont prêtes à lever les
sanctions le terrain pour parvenir à un
accord sur les questions nucléaires est
tout à fait prêt
ranta que la russie et l'iran sont
également tous les deux accusés d'
organiser constamment des crimes dans le
cyber-espace de pratiquer par exemple
cyber espionnage et cyber attaques
contre d'autres états dans quelle mesure
de tête accusations sont elles
justifiées et à quoi sert-elle
à nice la donne
vous avez dû entendre parler de la
cyberattaque contre les stations-service
iranienne
hier la coiffure il y a eu une telle
attaque
d'où vient cette attaque qui secoue la
haute garonne elle a été commise par
ceux qui mènent de telles attaques eux
mêmes nikon en sapant les communications
dans divers pays
en particulier les communications
cybernétique et compris en iran
rawdonnois qu ils ont eux-mêmes reconnu
avoir mené une cyber attaque sur nos
infrastructures nucléaires ils l'ont
annoncé officiellement
la loire et les sionistes et les pays
qui aspirent à la domination ils l'ont
annoncé
il leur a permis de perpétrer de telles
attaques
nous menons des activités nucléaires
pacifiques
ils nous attaquent
après ils le reconnaissent
beachhead à lille pour quelles raisons
dans les chemins de quoi attaquer vous
nos scientifiques nucléaires
il meurt en martyr
il ya des gens qui ont besoin d'essence
et vous fragiliser le système de nos
stations service
bien sûr nous avons immédiatement pris
une décision compte tenu des progrès en
matière de cybernétique en iran
et comme nous avons de très bons experts
dans ce domaine
mme oda nous avons évidemment normaliser
la situation en très peu de temps et
tout a été relancée
laquelle ils nous collent et néanmoins
c'est ce qu'ils font eux il indiqué en
emblème ans les autres d'avoir rosario
est
malade et c'est évidemment un malheur au
malheur pour les peuples du monde zone
de production de lait mais ceux qui
oppriment les autres qui en même temps
mais non officiellement des attaques
terroristes officiellement les gens en
plein jour j'ai même des cyber attaques
en plein jour alors le micro
ils ont commis un attentat contre notre
grand commandant de la résistance et
héros de la lutte contre le terrorisme
dans le monde qassem soleimani et contre
ses associés à bout mais 9h50 le
commandant de haut rang de la lutte
contre le terrorisme et héros de la
lutte contre le terrorisme en irak
ils les tuent et ces gens meurent en
martyr et il en accuse les autres ils
veulent faire passer l'oppresseur pour
l'opprimé et l'oppresseur l'oppresseur
et les peuples du monde ont les yeux
ouverts ils comprennent qu'ils
responsables de l'oppression dans le
monde
[Musique]
il y à une autre accusation qu on entend
souvent à l'égard de la russie et de
l'iran c'est que ces pays se comportent
de manière agressive destructrice envers
les autres pays
vous avez probablement déjà entendu les
clichés américains sur le rôle
destructeur de l'iran au moyen-orient
que diriez vous à ceux qui répandent de
telles rumeurs et parle de cette façon
casa les terrasses pour skype takis nous
quitte
je voudrais poser une question d'ordre
qui a créé dès
qu'il a mis au monde
ils ont commis des crimes terribles
dèche
ils ont commis de très gros crimes
contre des enfants des femmes et des
personnes vulnérables en syrie
ou dans d'autres pays de la région en
irak
et maintenant ils tuent des gens en
afghanistan
dans une mosquée où des musulmans cent
deux cents personnes étaient en train de
prier
ce sont des crimes horribles que des
jeux comme et dans le monde entier
ce qui sape la sécurité internationale
là ce sont ceux qui ont créé des shs
ceux qui soutiennent des ch
ce sont ceux qui pour ainsi dire mines
la sécurité en syrie depuis de
nombreuses années et c'est pareil en
irak et pendant deux décennies ils ont
été présents en afghanistan
vous voyez les américains ont été
présents en afghanistan pendant deux
décennies est le résultat de cette
présence qui a duré une vingtaine
d'années en plus de la guerre de
l'effusion de sang en ruine et
destruction ce sont des milliers de
maisons détruites des milliers d'enfants
des enfants handicapés des milliers de
personnes tuées opprimés en afghanistan
du fait de la domination américaine
et ça c'est les résultats de cette
présence qui a été si coûteuse
chiche qu'est ce que cela apporte l
afghanistan
nous voyons aujourd'hui combien de
problème il existe en afghanistan
par conséquent je pense que oui il est
juste que les américains aient quitté
l'afghanistan
l'irak cran plus tôt pour dire les
choses autrement il est juste qu'ils en
aient été expulsés
mais le fait qu'aujourd'hui les
américains ont changé leurs instruments
de guerre ils ont changé leurs armes
sous certains aspects ils les ont changé
sous d'autres noms par exemple ils
utilisent l'instrument des sanctions
vis-à-vis de ceux qui veulent travailler
ils disent eh bien cette personne est
indépendante donc il faut introduire des
sanctions à son encontre
et il impose ses sanctions à la fois aux
journalistes et aux personnes influentes
des divers pays
ces gens sont sous le coup de sanctions
américaines
agathe si on voit que quelqu'un est un
des prenant influents ou pour ainsi dire
que ces actions vont à l'encontre du
système de domination des intérêts des
américains des sanctions seront
introduites contre cette personne
une question sur un autre sujet la
coopération par exemple vous développer
activement votre coopération avec la
chine
divers domaines vous entretenez des
relations avec la chine quelle place la
chine occupe-t-elle désormais dans la
politique étrangère de l'iran
la russie auraient-elles une raison
d'être envieuses
non non non a besoin d'être envieux
parce que nous avons des liens avec la
chine et nous avons des liens et des
contacts avec la russie
avec les pays de la région qui veulent
avoir des relations avec nous
s'il s'agit de relation fondée sur des
intérêts communs des relations fondées
sur des intérêts mutuels le respect
mutuel alors bien sûr nous allons
développer ces relations
nous avons également des relations
stratégiques avec la chine
et nous allons aussi bien sûr avoir des
contacts avec les pays qui veulent des
relations fondées sur nos intérêts
communs le respect mutuel le bon
voisinage
ainsi que sur l'utilisation des
capacités des deux pays dans l'intérêt
du bien-être des peuples le confort des
peuples
et notre relation avec tous les pays qui
veulent avoir des relations avec la
république islamique d'iran sera fondée
comme je lé 10 sur le bénéfice mutuel et
le respect mutuel
et même avec ceux qui sont
géographiquement éloignés de nous mais
avec qui nous avons de bonnes relations
nous entretiendrons bien sur ses
relations
et nous pensons qu'à l'égard de la
russie de la chine et de certains autres
pays ce sera sans doute notre vision
parlons d'une autre région pas l'asie
centrale mais le moyen-orient où la
russie et l'iran coopère également sur
diverses questions
d'après vous quels sont les principaux
vecteurs de coopération ici au
moyen-orient
vous savez nous travaillons pour assurer
la sécurité et la paix en asie centrale
rossi est
et nous pensons que cette région doit
évidemment être épargnés de toute
déstabilisation par les efforts de tous
les pays de la région
nous sommes prêts à travailler avec les
pays du caucase et d'asie centrale
à d'oeuvrer pour la paix et la
tranquillité dans cette région
que pouvez-vous dire de la volonté de
l'iran de s'intégrer davantage à l'os et
s dans quelle mesure est ce important
pour vous et d'après vous l'osce et ace
sera t-elle dominante à travers l'espace
eurasien
comme
vous savez je pense que l'organisation
de coopération de shanghai
l'organisation dont l'iran est devenu
membre à part entière peut évidemment
entretenir de bonnes relations avec les
pays de la région asiatique et cela
profitera à toutes les régions ce sont
des relations commerciales et
économiques
il s'agit de coopération en matière de
sécurité de culture et ainsi de suite et
des mesures ont déjà été prises à cet
effet mais il me semble que
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai devrait être plus active et la
communauté économique eurasiatique aussi
l'union économique eurasienne est
également une structure qui peut être
bénéfique à la région si elle agit de
manière plus active vous voyez nous
avons des organisations et des
structures régionales nous pensons
qu'elles forment une bonne condition
préalable au développement de la
coopération inter régionale de la
coopération entre les pays de la région
et il ya de la place pour le
développement des opportunités pour les
uns et les autres cela conduira au
développement de la région et empêchera
l'intrusion d'état étranger est là par
conséquent les capacités de la région
peuvent être exploitées au maximum
à machault de parlons de la pandémie
l'iran et la russie ont été durement
touchés par le coronavirus et ses effets
existe-t-il une coopération entre nos
deux pays sur ce sujet
concernant le coronavirus
je pense que le monde entier a dû
retenir une leçon et cette leçon c'est
le fait que malgré tous les outils dont
possède les superpuissances il n'a pas
été possible
de faire de la prévention ni de trouver
une approche appropriée pour combattre
le corona virus
et la lutte contre le chron un virus est
une sorte de travail collégial une sorte
d'action conjointe des coalitions
ainsi à cet égard je voudrais remercier
la chine la russie et les autres pays
qui ont coopéré avec nous dans ce
domaine
bien sûr maintenant nous avons pu
prendre les mesures appropriées
bon perdant l'essentiel est que nous
avons effectué la vaccination des gens
aujourd'hui une grande partie de notre
peuple est vaccinée
cela nous permettra de sauver de
protéger notre peuple de cette
catastrophe
quand j'étais chef du gouvernement
chaque jour à peu près 700 familles
perdait des proches
aujourd'hui qu'il y à peu près 20 décès
par jour
il s'agit donc d'un taux très faible
l'incidence est très faible et le taux
de mortalité est également très faible
et il a baissé encore
faut-il qu néanmoins nous restons
vulnérables à cette nouvelle attaque
cette nouvelle souche omicron
il ne sommes pas non plus protégés
par conséquent nous devons faire des
efforts pour que notre peuple et
d'autres peuples ne souffre pas de cette
nouvelle souche un col nous avons une
très bonne coopération entre l'iran et
la russie sur cette question
nous avons une coopération scientifique
ainsi qu'une coopération sur le vaccin
je voudrais remercier tous les pays qui
ont fait des efforts et coopérer avec
nous dans ce domaine et gamme quai et
dire qu'une telle coopération
une telle disons coalition d'efforts
peut permettre de protéger les peuples
d'asie
je voulais aussi vous poser une question
sur qassem suleimani
que j'ai d'ailleurs rencontré à
plusieurs reprises en travaillant en
syrie récemment lors des commémorations
vous avez déclaré que s'il n'y a pas de
tribunal international et d' enquête sur
le meurtre de solesmes annie par trump
la nation iranienne tout entière se
vengerait
dites moi s'il vous plaît était ce un
avertissement ou peut-être une menace
vous savez qu sm soleymani appartenait
non seulement au peuple iranien mais
également à l'oumma musulmane
il est venu sauver des vies il a fait
des efforts dans ce sens
est évidemment tout le monde musulmans
et non musulmans respectent beaucoup son
travail
et il respecte son travail parce qu'ils
savent qu'il a pu sauver le peuple des
attaques des ennemis de l'humanité
je parle des groupes comme des ch et les
takfiri
gaulois et à cri
il a su protéger et sauver des vies
sa présence en syrie en irak dans la
région
s'inscrivait donc dans le cadre de la
lutte contre le terrorisme et de la
lutte pour la vie des gens
tout le monde dans le monde le sait
donc qassem suleimani si on en parle est
un héros de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
et les américains doivent répondre de
leurs actes
c'est une question de conscience
éveillée deux mesures vous dites que
vous êtes le fleuron de la lutte contre
le terrorisme
alors pourquoi le héros de la lutte
contre le terrorisme at il été tuées
au taquet qu'est-ce qui est pourquoi
vous m'aidiez allemands disent ses
camarades ont ils été tuées
et vous l'avouer devant tout le monde
officiellement
ils ont commis un énorme crime london
irish et
celui qui commet un si grand cri et
avoue lui-même ce crime doit
naturellement être puni par un tribunal
approprié il faut les juger ils doivent
passer par ce processus judiciaire
devant un tribunal approprié compétent
il va adhérer
il s'agit d'une promesse de protéger les
opprimés et de punir les oppresseurs et
ceux qui ont sont responsables zalman
l'a71 évidemment c'est une promesse
sincère et cette promesse sera tenue
bien sûr
la spadine président yann monsieur le
président merci beaucoup pour cette
interview nous sommes le premier média
international choisi par vous pour
exprimer vos opinions nous vous
souhaitons beaucoup de succès
a dit non merci beaucoup et un grand
merci aussi à tous vos amis ainsi qu'aux
représentants des médias qui ont
participé merci
[Musique]